thank you
so i'm going to revisit a question that
has been asked before
and that is
can it help
knowing that there is just few solutions
to an npr problem
one hand you
your intuition tells you that if there
are more needles in the hay well then it
should be easier to find one right but
there could also be that
one needle forms kind of a structure
could you move your microphone higher no
okay
okay yeah do you hear me now
yeah okay
so
so you can imagine that there is some
kind of structure that will guide the
the search
and make it easier to solve the problem
if there's just a few number of
solutions
so but like i said this has been studied
before and what we know is
that it cannot help too much
because there is this uh reduction by
valiant and vasilani
that
if you can solve unique set
really fast like two to the n to some
bit low or one time
then the randomized exponential time
hypothesis is false
so this means that for every np-hard
problem that has a parsimonious
polynomial time reduction
from satisfiability uniqueness cannot
help you a lot
if you if we look at satisfiability
alone then it's even worse because
uniqueness doesn't help at all
so if you have
just a slightly faster algorithm for
unique sets then you also will have one
for the general case so this strong
exponential time hypothesis in a
randomized sense will be false
but perhaps uniqueness helps for other
np-hard problems and this is what i'm
going to talk about today i think it
makes sense when we look at this
fine-grained
perspective of things and this is two
candidates that we've come up with
where uniqueness might help
so the first example is finding a
hamiltonian cycle in a direct graph
and here i look
at the runtime parameterized by the
number of vertices
or finding a vertex k coloring in a
bounded degree graph parameterized by
the path width
so
the general
paradigm i use
for algorithms that benefit from few
solutions
is that i in the first step make a
connection between the wanted objects
the solutions to the problem
and something
else that is more easily counted
so i turn apples into pairs and then i
count the currencies of the pairs
and deduce from what that outcome
if there is a solution or not to the
original problem
so we will see these two examples of
this paradigm
so
remind you of what is the directed
hamiltonian cycle problem you're given a
directive graph and you want to find
a tour visiting every vertex exactly
once
so for this particular instance there
are two solutions
so this is the first apple
and this is the other one
but we're not going to count apples
directly we're going to
count pairs
pairs so
our pairs will be vertex partitions with
certain
certain
constraints
so we will look at partitions of the
vertices in three groups x y and z which
would be red green and blue respectively
and the vertices and x are special
because they need an odd number of arcs
ending in the other parts whereas the
vertices in the
part y
must have an odd number of arcs ending
in y and the same holds for said
and because of this symmetry in y and
said
we only count
one of the two solutions obtained by
switching the role of y and z
so this looks like a
strange problem uh a strange
partition problem that is not
directly related to
hamiltonian cycles
but
we showed that uh the number of
hamiltonian cycles
and the number of such xyz partitions
actually are equal of modulo 2.
and i
will not bother you with the proof now
it's
pretty straightforward but
still it
it there is no
there is no
understanding from looking at the
partitions how they really relate to the
to the cycles but nevertheless we will
see a few
beautiful colorful pictures here
to demonstrate demonstrate this
so if we look at the instance we had
with the two hamiltonian cycles
this is one
such partition
you see here that
all the green
vertices has one and only one neighbor
in the green
and the blue has one and only one
neighbor in the blue
whereas the red has one neighbor of the
other kind
like this
so that is one such valid
partition
it turns out that there are eight
such partitions altogether
and it's hard to to see
see some
structure here related to the
hamiltonian cycles but
still these are the partitions
and we know that this is an even number
and remember the instance had an even
number of hamiltonian cycles
so if we take the instance we had and
just flip
one arc so it goes the other way
we destroy one of the solutions
and we're left with only one apple
so if we take this instance instead and
look at the partitions
we have another example
so here again you see that
the
green ones has just one
neighbor
and the red one has
like one
uh one neighbor in the green side
and it turns out that there is
only three
such partitions here
which is an odd number
and remember the instance had an odd
number of solutions
so this means that potentially we can
attack the parity problem for
for hamiltonisity by counting these
partitions instead
but we're still in problem because i
mean counting the partitions they are
three to the n of them
so
just doing it like a brute force
fashion won't work
so we need a better idea and that idea
is
we count the partitions by first finding
all possible parts y
so all possible green parts that can be
part of any partition
and if you remember the green the the
green vertices the y vertices needed one
no an odd number of neighbors in itself
and if you do the following trick that
you add
a self loop to the vertices
uniformly and independently
independently at random
we can
make
this the probability of a versus being
in being in a green part independent of
the other ones
and adding a self-loop doesn't affect
hamiltonicity obviously you can never
use a self-loop
so if you count this it's
you get that there is
1.5 to the n y parts in expectation
but it's not that easy because we also
need an algorithm that
lists them efficiently
but we figure out how to do that in the
golden ratio to the end time
so we can actually
list these green parts and once we have
the green parts
we can use a linear algebra to count the
number of partitions for the remaining
vertices in the two parts x and zed
so that is just gauss a gaussian
elimination
and looking at the rank
so this means
that
we get a 1.618 to the end time algorithm
that we'll see if there is
we can separate the case when we have
one hamiltonian cycle or no hamiltonian
cycle
and if we
augment this with a recent result with
dell and his felt
uh as there's a parrot dilemma which
essentially just
flips a biased coin for each edge
to see if i should keep it or not
and then
with a certain probability there would
be an odd number
of
solutions depending on how many
solutions there were to begin with
we get this n choose k
times
1.618 to the end time algorithm
if they have at most 2 to the k
hamiltonian cycles so this means that we
can have an exponential number of
hamiltonian cycles and still beat the 2
to the end time
which is the best known general
algorithm for the director case
there is uh some progress
as
siegen al showed like three years ago
that for bipartites directed graphs you
can do one point
nine to the n essentially
still we don't know
what is a general directed case so here
you can
think what does this mean if
we're thinking in terms of can we prove
a seth's lower bound
on directed hamiltonicity
well then
it seems like you will need
the reduction to make the number of
cycles
a lot of them a lot of them
so it gives some hint on what that
reduction would look like
okay
so that was the the first example
the second example is k coloring
and
let me remind you again what is the
problem you have this undirected graph
and you want to put
a color on each vertex from a palette of
k colors
and this particular instance there is a
unique
three coloring
unique in the sense that
up to permutations of the colors there
is no other coloring
so this is the only apple for this
instance
but again we're not going to count
the apples so the pears here will will
be sub graphs
and we will orient the edges of the
graph making it a direct graph
and we will also add vertex degree
constraints and we will count sub graphs
such that the difference between the
outgoing arcs and the incoming arcs
equals the constraint on the vertex for
every vertex
counted module k
so this is how k enters
into the equation here
and we also say that the sub graph is
even if it uses an even number of arcs
and odd otherwise
so what is the connection between apples
and pears
well
it turns out that for any orientation
and any choice of degree constraints if
you can't color the graph with k colors
then it has the same number of even and
odd such subgroups and this is basically
the alohan tarzi theorem if you just
tweak it a bit
but the more interesting part is the
second one which shows that
for any orientation and at least the
fraction one over s
of all the choices of these degree
constraints
a k column graph which has s a positive
number s of solutions will get a
different number of even an odd such
subgroups
so again i will not give the proof
but rather show these colorful pictures
so
so this is how the instance could look
when you have
putting an orientation on the edges and
added some modular degree constraints
so
remember we're looking at three
colorability here
so the constraint is either zero one or
two
so
what does an even sub graph look like
here well
even means that it uses an even number
of green
arcs here so you can count them and you
can see that they actually there are ten
of them i believe one two three four
five seven eight okay
and
if you look at the degree constraints
you remember that the number of outgoing
arcs minus the number of incoming should
be equal to the degree constraint so
here it is two
because there are two outgoing arcs
here it is two because there is one
incoming arc
so this is where the modulo three
arithmetic comes in
so up here there was
one outgoing
you have examples of two outgoing
you are more interesting examples here
when we have a cancellation between two
and then one going out and so on
so it turns out there are three even
such
sub graphs
so what about the old ones
so another one here we'll use an odd
number of arcs one two three four five
six seven eight nine
and again you see that this we have two
outgoing
we have one incoming
one canceled cancels and one outgoing
and it turns out that there are six of
these
so this is a different number of even an
old so i could
if you remember my connection you can
conclude that it is indeed a
three-column graph
so what if we destroy that property
if we add a single arc and remember the
original instance was uniquely three
colorable so by
putting an arc between two vertices that
had the same color in that coloring we
are forcing a fourth color the gel one
but we keep all the
degree constraints
and if we look at
now look at the even and odd subgraphs
of course we have all the old
old solutions but we also have a lot of
new ones
so it actually turns out that there's a
20 even and there's 20 odd
here so we have broken the three
colorability
property and thereby we end up with this
balanced situation
so what does this mean algorithm wise
how can we use this to make a faster
algorithm
so i will first briefly
mention the concept of a path
path decomposition it
basically means that
you're thinking of you can think of the
vertices order from left to right and
you're sweeping a bag which contains all
vertices which has dependencies to the
verses
to the right
and
in that bag you encode information of
how you partially can color
the
the graph use the part of the graph that
you've seen
so
this natural algorithm which
uses
uh for each
way of color the subgraph that we've
seen so far
we tabulate for each way of
coloring
the bag
if this is possible or not
so there is uh k colors to choose from
and the the path width is the size of
the largest bag needed
so you will need hey to the path with
number of states
sweeping from left to right here
and this is something that people have
thought about maybe we can
do better than this
but it turns out that probably we can't
so
not too long ago
looks down on microsoft
showed that you can't even
go slightly below this k to the path
with
every positive eps below k
will imply that the strong exponential
time hypothesis is wrong
so
that's
it's a bit of a downer for us so we have
to do something to get around of this
and
what i suggest is that okay
let's look at bounded degree
so
if we also assume that every vertex has
degree bounded by d and we're looking
for
a k color ability for some k that is
larger than half
of this max degree
this is still an interesting problem
because it's already np heart the
three-color degree four graph and this
comes from the
hollier's
proof from
for edge coloring and you just like the
line graph that construction
and once we have gotten to this
and we're
we're counting these sub graphs instead
we're in a situation where
for each vertex in the bag
it suffices to remember
how
what is
the current
in out degree minus in degree situation
but we can forget all configurations
where there is no possibility
to patch up a valid solution with the
remaining arcs
so this is sort of a meet-in-the-middle
algorithm
so you can throw away a lot of the
states here
so this means that we end up with a d
over 2 plus 1 to the power with volume
time
algorithm and remember k was larger than
this by assumption
and then we have something that is
exponentially larger
exponentially faster than the natural
algorithm
and even assuming such a max degree
bound i don't think it is known how to
else elsewhere
improve on this k to the path with a
natural algorithm
that was pretty much what i had to say
so this is just the references
thank you
your pairs seem kind of magical how did
you think of them i don't think of them
i
i work with the equations and see what
what ends up what i end up with
backwards
yeah so so start with things like
inclusion exclusion
i agree they i mean in retrospect it
seems odd but it's related yes
so there is some kind of a method you
can work backwards from being
so what your guess is it's going to be
somewhat easier for the general color
for the general dress
the unique case is going to be easier or
equally hard
yeah
i mean this is my question to you is
this is this just some intermediate
results where there is actually a
general algorithm which is
as fast or even faster than
i showed or
is this a symptom
something that we haven't seen before we
haven't looked at this scale
before
not for these problems for
satisfiability we have but
mohan your intuition is the opposite
right i don't know i don't know about
coloring that much i haven't thought of
coloring
okay
satisfied with the day
yeah
but for this is as close as disagreement
as we ever get right actually having
opposing intuitions about uh
whether or not the number of solutions
makes it easier or harder we're close to
the fight you mentioned earlier yes
yes i think you can make any kind of
general comments of how to turn
say these kind of
natural um permutation problems
in the sense hamiltonian cycle is in a
sense yeah into something which uses
these kind of partitions because they
they lead to a similar exponential time
instead of well kind of
yeah
so so maybe there is a more general
principle here if you remember the first
example we turned sub-graphs into
partitions and in the second
part we turn partitions into subgraphs
so maybe there is some more general
structure here
i don't know
okay